healing is is learning from your
mistakes yeah learning what you may have
love for wearing is yeah like yeah
self-aware
if you learn though definitely yeah
literally I'm just doing whatever so I
have this
oh God literally I have this Theory
right so because because I've met a
couple of women on this healing journey
and and there's there's always a couple
of patterns all right firstly there's
the whole like basically they're going
for like more emotionally impactful
moments that normally includes getting
with another Chad
Etc normally they come back with
a heightened ego so it's more like
normally I hear this it's kind of like
yeah I shouldn't have they say one thing
negative about themselves and it's
always like a false negative it's always
like I was too loving attention to
details I was too nice I gave too much
stuff like that and then they go on a
list about how everyone else was crap
you know this guy did this that guy was
talking but I was also too loving and
it's like it's like their way of being
like [ __ ] up accountable what if
those other women you met though well I
can only speak from experience I'm not
it's a theory right it's not I haven't
said it's like you know how the world
works this is how I think but why you
attract these kind of women yeah
no but it's like it's like the false
negative is saying like I'm bad with
about like I it's funny I always hear
this too it's like girls always say like
I'm bad with boundaries and it's like a
way to say it's everyone else and not me
no but yeah it's you no because because
it's me letting them do what they want
you still yeah it's still a false like
they understand
I feel like it's easier to deflect than
be accountable in it it's definitely
easier to say oh this person gets me
angry or they do this to me instead of
saying you know what I can be a bad
person at times or I can get real
triggers oh I don't exactly so yeah
that's all yeah I think it's it's like
it's normally I think the issues
normally from those the women I've met
two or three who are very very
intelligent you know Oxford Cambridge
educated who are reasonable in a lot of
ways but I've noticed that that point
they try and make an emotional situation
rational and when they rationalize it it
tends towards narcissism in my view so
I'll finish that theory right so they
come off with their one thing that's bad
with me 10 things that's bad with
everyone else and then normally they
they they come out of that with
heightened expectations from everyone
else except for themselves so they're
normally kind of like oh you know
I don't have time like you're bad I'm
not dealing with it I've been to therapy
you know
they've got all the answers for everyone
else after this healing Journey but I've
noticed that they're less feminine now
like they're more into themselves they
tend to use words like I'm doing me now
this is a me dated which I think is like
not really the point of relationship
like coming out with a bad relationship
more self-focused isn't helping you find
a better relationship it's just making
you more more narcissistic like you're
you're giving less now self-centered you
know you've just convinced yourself that
you've grown but actually you're giving
less and you're more you're less patient
with people and you're you're less able
to sustain healthy relationships because
you're more judgmental Now using the
guise of therapy and this and that that
means
and then and then that's I've heard this
from so many guys where they're saying
like basically then they'll have these
high standards and all these things they
expect from a guy but it's like you're
making me pay new prices for a used
battered damaged product yeah
and they'll be like or or then they'll
make the next guy wait because of all
the damage they had from before but
there he's like but the last guy didn't
have to wait before the one before and
and I guess like the way guys look at it
is like over a certain age they just see
it as you've let someone like someone's
gotten in for free yeah but again it
comes down to what I would say people
need to be accountable yeah we women
need to be accountable and men need to
be accountable it's very clear-cut yeah
do you know what I mean that's just to
be honest as well
why were you fired from your last job I
worked too hard said no man ever
I gave too much
your theories are very well thought out
that's what I think so far
okay guys I'm gonna take a second to
read super chats
um guys all super chats go towards
updates in the studio I appreciate you
all so much for sending super chats
because it really helps us invest in a
bigger place next year I want to get a
three four bedroom I wanna I wanna max
out all the different rooms and make
different Studios so we can start
channels for people like Auntie and
other people that want to start channels
and even do smash or past dating shows
we're gonna make a bunch of different
channels in this house but we need Super
chats and we need memberships especially
memberships to fund it and keep it going
on top of that guys go follow my
Instagram it's just.pearly things I'm
trying to get to 30k followers on
Instagram so that's really important we
also have a twitch page a Facebook page
and also also go follow I say Facebook
twitch oh and our new clips Channel yeah
yeah so our super chats I saw a bunch
from zontience shout out to you I'm
pulling it up really quick on my thing
okay
so um we got one from ATA women want to
submit to a man not a tyrant lifted by
the wind Pearl why are women so afraid
to compromise with men why so resistant
to change Joshua Cintron men don't feel
safe to be vulnerable because modern
women take full advantage of that Mr
negative men talk about their friends
men talk to their friends they listen
empathize but don't try to fix it
soja for Christ we are at War ladies
that say y'all are independent and don't
need a man one where is that man two you
will never be independent of man society
is built kept running by men three if my
woman told me she didn't need me I would
say there is the door Peter quit
Peter Quinn women from Sierra Sierra
Leone okay okay
um have have you heard of Ishmael Bay
the author his Memoir was amazing A Long
Way Gone bless your country
um the UK Economist remember women who
are not traditional cannot expect
tradition a traditional man only a tiny
percentage of women qualify for these
men
um Doug MPA so much missandry feminism
freed up women from having to be
barefoot and pregnant feminism also
freed up men from having to provide for
women you ladies created the world where
men don't have to grow up enjoy it
ladies Gus if
I do if
um Gus if women were more marriageable
more men would step up 90 free-toe bet
why is Walter
Mercado on the show look him up LOL ATA
women hearing women healing sounds
expensive and oh ish
zontience was absentience a normal super
chat everyone clap everyone clap
everyone claps Shadow Adventures
um Kleenex the only reason you haven't
heard men talk about healing is because
the world doesn't care about men's
hardships and issues women expect men to
be the stability in their lives
regardless of what men experience even
to the man's detriment Soulja Boy for
Christ we are at War ladies most men
when hearing hearing you were on a
healing Journey especially red pill men
assume you were healing through writing
the CC which is like the carousel
that you can't okay okay I don't I don't
know what
what is sexual healing Chris
Chad let's go stream sponsor come on
come on
um did you know August is Jada Pinkett
Smith's favorite month to celebrate this
here is Jada's favorite here is Jada
Smith's quote it is important to
prioritize I know for me my family comes
first that makes every decision very
easy
men resent women who can't say when
enough is enough
uh Mr negative the best way to get over
one is to get under one the UK Economist
plea please
um please ask your guests oh I'm gonna
ask this in a second um the UK Economist
I'll come back to that um Joshua Clinton
healing is a cop-out it's a buzzword for
a trip to the Jersey Shore and avoid a
therapist like the plague
Matt butcher highly impressed with the
kleenex model cleaning up her life
ladies listen and learn text Sprint how
do y'all feel about someone that just
plays the consistent he did this she did
this card the X stories lie very deep in
my partner thoughts Chris another
hundred dollar Super Chat come on
um notice how the ladies always blame
men not taking any accountability and
fight back against Professional Therapy
they focus on things outside of
themselves because the focus in the
mirror is too painful zentians again why
do guys lie although most men of value
will be brutally honest just reflect on
the fact that the top 20 percent of men
are the ones passing around the majority
of women so when you want to pre
reproduce the bottom 80 of men do what
they can to get it
um smays
um
semi-tagen is it my mic just got
okay it's still going
um zentians to the kleenex women if sex
is just physical I can't hear it again
yeah yeah oh no I can't okay to the
kleenex women if sex is just physical
then why did the woman leech off her
husband for years only to show her True
Colors by demolishing her husband's
Pride feelings and Trust by asking for
that illicit Death Wish Vincent De La
Salle Jr if my wife ever had the
ostacity to disrespect me by asking to
sleep with her ex one last time I'd have
the audacity to pull that troll
um Jerome Barham Denver Colorado 39
years old 120k in net worth in the
medical field credit scores eight twenty
five nine BMI 20 homeowner I don't want
a leftover woman for a life partner how
would you suggest that I found a more
pure woman
um what would I say I mean it's hard
these days but I will say
see I want to say churches like certain
churches but then like you also get the
opposite in church something yeah yeah
so
um
I don't know I I've always found that
like girls that have hobbies and are um
more like doing things
um don't do as much like partying I
think it's better to go for girls that
aren't super big Partiers I guess yeah
that's what I would say yeah I think men
get so used to the game that you start
to like toxic or not toxic women about
women who play games okay and you know
after a while dating you meet a nice
pure decent girl and you're like she's a
bit too simple though yeah
a bigger compromise between like that
that bad bad B in the club and you know
huh and a sweet one yeah yeah it's that
saying like good guys never win it's the
same thing like we want the good guys
it's so much more attracted to the bad
guys like in the end yeah they always
win because you end up compromising on
what you initially wanted
know I think I don't think they win
because they get the leftover women
like it's like it's like you can't you
can't say you win when you get that like
when you get the women at less value
yeah it's not fun I don't enjoy that at
like but I'm gonna be less valuable in
10 years but it's just true I'm sadly
yeah because you're the last one left
yeah yeah but you might not be the last
one left because you might have they
might have been working towards and then
they're just they're there you are what
do you mean like they might have been
working towards their careers and then
all of a sudden they're like now I'm
ready and then it's you know picking up
from what is well I think but I think
the issue is I mean typically like if
guys accomplish or accomplished in their
career they date younger women yeah you
so so it's like but a lot of times a
complaint I hear is like even though
they might have met that girl later like
they know she would have rejected them
in her 20s yeah and so it's the same
concept as like the alpha winner because
the whole concept is she really wants
the guys from her 20s she's just
settling and in her head even though
that's not settling it's just her level
yeah as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible